[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
marine le pen wants to be france's first
far-right president and she's
campaigning hard in the run-up to the
second round at a rally in the southern
french city of avignon she said that if
elected should create jobs tackle
inflation and protect workers from
globalization promises that she hopes
will convince voters including those on
the left
the cost of living a quality education
good housing and living standards your
freedom has no price
le pen's supporters say she represents
something new and they don't want
another five years of emmanuel macron
her rival in the presidential race
he's aggressive he's full of himself i
want change
marine le pen is human she stands for
ordinary people macron isn't for real
people it's sad just look at the past
five years
le pen's focus on the cost of living in
this election has certainly widened her
appeal she's also softened her image but
the makeover hasn't changed her tough
anti-immigration anti-eu agenda that
some say would divide france
arnold is a nurse he moved to avignon 15
years ago from paquino faso
he says le pen presidency would be
dangerous for france so he's campaigning
for macron
people say the cost of living has gone
up under macron but that's totally false
that's just what le pen or melancholic
supporters say but macron has done a lot
to raise purchasing power these past
years
the centrist incumbent macron is also
courting left-wing voters and people who
are undecided in a battle that appears
to be a rerun of the 2017 race but is
widely expected to be much tighter which
way it will go is impossible to predict
but those here believe that their moment
has come natasha butler al jazeera
avignon france